oh god
mourners returned to the scene on sunday
to remember the dead and attempt to make
sense of what investigators describe as
a racially motivated hate crime in my 65
years in buffalo i've never seen
anything like this
never we survived the gang era the drug
area and now this we go this too shall
pass we're going to survive this as well
police say the suspect 18-year-old
payton gendron shot 13 people at a
neighborhood grocery store killing ten
most were african-american one aaron
salter was a security guard and a
retired police officer he was a nice guy
you know he cared about the community he
looked after the store investigators say
the suspect had been detained in the
past for threatening remarks but never
criminally charged and that a manifesto
that he appears to have written shows
his actions were racially motivated the
state police had
brought this individual in for a mental
health evaluation
he went to the local hospital he was
there for the information we have is
about a day and a half was evaluated and
then released at that point the buffalo
shooting is just the latest act of
violence in a country struggling with
racial tension gun violence and a surge
in hate crimes prompting calls from
elected officials from the governor all
the way up to the president for change
we must all work together to address the
hate that remains a stain
on the soul of america
the hearts are heavy once again
but a resolve
must never ever waver
new york's governor called for stronger
gun control laws this also calls for a
national response what was used
was not able to be purchased legally in
the state of new york the basic gun was
but the high capacity magazine
associated with it had to come from
another state because it is illegal in
the state of new york we need a smart
national policy she said the
investigation would also focus on what
more could have been done to stop him
kristen salumi al jazeera new york